not bro I mean look man one time when I
was a young kid in Korea right I was out
in the countryside cuz that's where my
mom's family's from and you know we're
talking about farms and then they're
kind of behind the times right in terms
of Technology and everything just a very
slow pace of life I saw this cow and it
was just right there so I was like I've
never [ __ ] seen a cow in real life
before I went up to the cow and I
started petting it right oh good cow
right and this guy [ __ ] I don't know
her starts oh [ __ ] scared the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I so I thought it he owned the cow
right and then he was mad that I was
touching his cow but then I realized he
was not saying anything it was just
noises coming out as a mouth I was like
it scared I was like bro ten years old
or something right scared the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of me right I [ __ ] ran I
booked it I [ __ ] ran to my
grandparents house and I told him like
dude this dude just [ __ ] ran up on me
and started like making noises and
yelling at me I was just petting a cow
and then they they're like what'd he
look like and I described him oh he had
a bald head and it's like oh that's just
too cheeky
right that was his name he's probably a
little are worded like oh he's just the
local [ __ ] has already known that he
suffered from mental retardation you
know or he was I'm sorry if that's not
politically correct he was mentally
challenged yeah and he just [ __ ] roam
the streets doing whatever you know and
solid [ __ ] yeah it's it's like literally
a village over there and and like people
just already knew so they're just like
oh that's just too cheeky you know
that's just too cheeky being too cheeky
is like a country bumpkin oh okay and
like you know at the time like I
couldn't really grasp it but I was like
I kind of understood on some level he he
just has something wrong with him so
when I saw him again fear turned into
just kind of right
now like are you just crazy yeah cuz
yeah he did that [ __ ] again he started
like making noises at me and I was just
kind of like alright you know like it's
just what it is what it is but yeah I do
know that people have become much more
sensitive to it and I'm not being
insensitive to it I'm just kind of
referencing it from a cultural
standpoint where we grew up in the 90s
and and people just kind of used the
word [ __ ]
that's hearted for a lot and it wasn't
saying it in like a negative way like oh
you're a mentally challenged person
she's like that's dumb
yeah it's just it's just dumb just just
like you know how using gay for things
became much more sensitive to right time
to change the lot man and I'm really
trying to keep up like I said if I slip
up every now and then yeah I know it was
like I said I didn't know about that
until this podcast people I know you
can't use that for anything now like
people just take you the wrong way right
I understand like it's not from a world
that I come because I don't I smell like
I have a child right was mentally you're
right it's a handicap mentally mentally
challenged or something yeah so it you
know obviously doesn't sting personally
yeah so I so I get it yeah like I'm
that's completely that's the thing like
I respect it you know what he's called
people to sheiks nothing on did but yeah
I I definitely am and in it that kind of
ties into the whole dog owner thing it
is being aware of like how it might come
across as somebody else right and then
so I gotta be respectful of that like
yeah I come from a time where we just
kind of used it passively without even
thinking about it and it wasn't
necessarily like such a strong
derogatory word it was just such a
common word yeah yeah yeah
but then once it started getting to a
point where you know it started becoming
more offensive to people then it's like
okay I got to be aware of that and I got
to respect that you know and if a
certain group of people or just people
in general are taking offense to it then
that's fine like I wonder when I'm
always like in this weird place with
when it comes to saying offensive stuff
and it comes to comedy right because
comedy is such a weird space because
yeah I feel like if it's for the
laughs and the joke is executed right
you can say whatever it right ever you
want right my great example is like make
Chappelle he did that yeah yeah I saw
that when he's talking about it in his
stand-up right yeah you know Dave
Chappelle talks about that stuff and
it's just I I feel like in the guy's a
comedy we can lose a lot of things if I
don't find it funny I'm allowed to not
find it funny yeah but I don't think
people should be canceled for it per se
right right even with that guy Shane
Gillis when he did that he he was that
comic that was supposed to be hired on
SNL and he was talking about how Asian
people are disgusting or something like
that right the reason why I found it
highly offensive I was kind of irritated
was because it wasn't a joke it was just
him saying like his [ __ ] Asian people
are disgusting right right
there was no bit yeah yeah yeah you know
other comics disagreed some some complex
your Rogen said that he thought it was a
bit and I was like nah Rogan you off on
this one that wasn't a bit like I know
what a joke is that's not that wasn't a
joke he was just being an [ __ ] right
specifically not him it was like I think
that's his brother or some [ __ ] was
being kind of weird with it but then
people are like yeah he should be
cancelled for it I'm like I don't know
about cancelled like I'm allowed to be
upset about I'm not the flayman for that
[ __ ] should you cancel them the human
side of me or the the you know the
Millennial person is kind of like maybe
he should but the comic sides of me like
oh but that's the thing though man is
like people are so [ __ ] sensitive now
you know what I mean like we're in
canceled culture right you get cancelled
for anything and everything and so like
people are such are so kind of afraid I
guess to do certain things say certain
things and look man it's like we're
human beings your allotted mistakes you
know what I mean you can make mistakes
as long as you own up to it you
recognize it and you improve on it right
like all right if you're if you're
[ __ ] raping people over and over
again that's just that's a whole nother
thing but if you genuinely weren't aware
or just had like a lapse in judgment
even right and might have said something
or did something that was offensive and
you didn't realize it at the time but
then you realize oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up and
you